[Music]
cyber insurance is a critical component
of an organization's security and risk
management program it can help protect
organizations from financially damaging
cyber attacks or security incidents from
errors in configuration so you get peace
of mind it also helps create proper
incentives to invest in cyber security
when we get home insurance for example
we usually have a pretty good idea of
how to reduce potential losses like
getting sprinklers or using brick to
build houses to prevent the spread of
fires or locks to secure your home but
with cyber insurance loss prevention
strategies are not as well understood
and experts May disagree on the impacts
of security controls cyber loss
prevention gets complicated because of
competing company priorities
understaffed cyber security teams and no
clear path on where to get the best Roi
on cyberspend on top of that insurance
companies are also struggling to get the
right information and to truly measure
the amount of cyber risk a customer
carries without comprehensive cyber risk
data coupled with external events like
the recent rise and ransomware attacks
cyber insurance has become significantly
more expensive and difficult to obtain
so you might be wondering how can you
protect your organization with these
constraints Google has been working to
help organizations Better manage their
cyber risk through the risk Protection
Program we developed the risk Protection
Program to help organizations gain
access to enhanced cyber insurance
coverage Google is in a position to help
set industry standards for security that
can then be directly linked to insurance
coverage Google's relationships with
insurance carriers globally also allows
us to drive better solutions for
customers the risk Protection Program
has two key components first risk
manager is a data security scorecard you
can use to measure manage and report on
your cyber risk with or without
insurance
second Google has partnered with
insurers who offer Cloud Protection Plus
which is a broad cyber insurance
coverage with built-in discounts
depending on your risk posture
the risk Protection Program solution is
designed to help Google Cloud customers
by providing them access to coverage
with specialized terms and a simple
application process
insurers by helping them gain better
cyber security data which they can more
directly correlate to potential losses
and Global cyber security risk reduction
by creating proper incentives we can
help reduce Global Security risk the
program operates in a shared fate model
where you and Google Cloud have skin in
the game for achieving strong security
outcomes the risk Protection Program
creates a virtuous cycle of risk
reduction by using risk manager you are
able to achieve a stronger security
posture reducing your risk as well as
obtain insurance coverage at a lower
cost through our partners you can then
reinvest the cost Savings in your
digital transformation efforts which
will also be protected as part of the
program and this cycle continues over
time so what do customers need to do to
get access to risk manager well it's
simple find the right stakeholder
internally who has admin permissions to
your Google Cloud console and have that
individual onboard the organization to
risk manager run a report utilizing risk
manager to understand and measure your
organization's security posture work
with Google's cyber security action team
or your own Security leaders to address
recommendations in the report now this
isn't required but it's always
recommended speak to your insurance
broker about the risk Protection Program
and send the report to Insurance
Partners to obtain access to a quote for
the program with the risk Protection
Program you get holistic risk assessment
and monitoring coupled with an industry
first insurance program among major
providers in short with a shared fate
approach we're working with you both
technically and commercially to share
your risk this program gives you an
effective and long-lasting security and
risk management partnership and strategy
and we consider this strongest risk
model for a modern Enterprise to help
you get started we have the tooling
Technical Resources and financial
incentives to reduce the cost and
efforts of your security implementation
stay tuned to see a demo of the risk
manager and risk Protection Program in
action
[Music]
[Music]